Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program, Rachel Bit of Cougher, who's an election
forecaster and analyst, host of the podcast
The Election Whisperer, founder of Strike
PAC.
And I think Rachel, someone who is increasingly
concerned about what twenty twenty two is
looking like for Democrats, am I right?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
I mean, you know, if you're a trained political
scientist like I am and your area of expertize
happens to be campaigns and elections, voter
behavior, there is no there's few trends in
that kind of research that is as adamant,
as robust, as continuous as the midterm effect.
So, you know, even before I mean, literally,
as I was walking across the stage and getting
inaugurated, the fundamentals of the cycle
are against the Democrats.
So, you know, given what happened in twenty
twenty, not only where they structurally had
this huge fundamentals advantage, but then
the events of twenty twenty could not have
set up a challenger trying to oust an incumbent
better than Joe Biden in that fight.
Right.
Seeing the Democrats unable to capitalize
on that down ballot and not just because it's
something that happens, right?
Like it's something you have to make the conditions
for.
And they did not do that.
Right.
We have a lot of problems that are in the
way our system infrastructure for electioneering
is all the way from organizational tactics
to strategy that make it distinct from the
Republican universe.
And so those two things combined should have
everybody concerned.
Speaker 1: So let's start with like the top
level and then work to the specifics of this
next election.
There's this general idea that you have the
control of the White House, which in one election
and then in that next midterm, the party that
takes control of the House I'm sorry, that
takes control of the White House, doesn't
do well in the House, often losing now.
It doesn't always happen, but it happens frequently.
What is there on top of that structural thing
that may be specific to the current slate
of Democrats and Republicans that concerns
you for twenty two?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, here, let me just
say, in terms of in terms of what you just
said about, you know, it doesn't always happen,
but it happens frequently.
Let me be very, very clear.
The last 40 midterm cycles in thirty eight
of them.
Right, the party suffered midterm loss in
the hyper polarized, polarized era, which
is a you know, if you think about soil periods
or anthropology or something like that, we're
living in a very distinct behavior pattern,
time period of hyper partizanship and polarization.
In that era.
We have seen these large midterm effects,
not that we've never seen large ones in history,
but we're seeing them kind of become the stable.
And of course, that is because we have this
very, very distinct, you know, two party coalition
set up right now.
We didn't always have these two parties took
a long time for them to institutionalize,
and now they have these very institutionalized
voting states that are ideologically homogenous,
that are especially in the Republican format,
very demographically homogenous.
And therefore, you don't have like a midterm
swing because people are like, you know, I
tried a I tried Coke and Pepsi.
Right.
That's not so much of what's happening.
There is always some voters moving choice,
you know, who are going from Coke to Pepsi.
But what's really powering these large midterms
is that the demographic composition of the
electorate is switching a lot of that switch.
By the way, David, is coming from.
Right.
OK, it comes from us participating and then
pulling back.
Right.
And that's that's what I'm trying to head
off.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Let's talk about that a little bit.
A couple of weeks ago, I said, you know, we
had a situation like you, like you're pointing
out 20, 20 was just ripe for Joe Biden to
to oust an incumbent.
Everything went wrong under Trump.
And then on top of that, you had this disastrous
pandemic response.
And still, while the popular vote margin was
big, it came down to relatively few hundred
thousand votes in a few states, the same way
that it did in twenty sixteen.
Twenty sixteen.
Could have gone, Hillary.
Twenty twenty could have gone.
Trump Right.
I imagine that with a Democrat in the White
House, maybe now this is more a twenty four
conversation than twenty two.
I don't think that Democrats will be as motivated
to reelect Joe Biden or if it's Kamala Harris
and Biden goes one term.
And so I worry that Republicans will be reinvigorated
by saying, let's get Trump back in.
And that's a real concern to me.
Is that concern warranted in your mind?
Speaker 5: That should make you guys all stay
up at night like it does me?
I mean, here I am days away out from an appendectomy,
and I'm doing the show today because it's
so urgent that I tell as many people as possible
and turn as many people as possible onto the.
Illusion, it's not like we have this problem
and you're getting a lot of oxygen about that
in the media.
But the solution is, is as equally I mean,
it's more important.
Right.
And the solution for us, if we can implement
it here, isn't so much it isn't just about
having the policy power.
It is about staving off potentially democratic
collapse.
So, you know, it's just so critical that people
understand on that other side, they think
they're the good guys, we're the bad guys,
because they're fed all of this hyper partizan
red meat.
It's constant crisis and threat.
Right.
And so with the things that they're doing
over there to dismantle democracy, they would
tell you are in defense of it.
And they believe that.
And we all know objectively that that's not
true.
And if we get confused, we can look at international
audiences to find out, are we doing groupthink
or are we actually right?
You know, and and it's and it's absolutely
the case that they they are going to be on
fire to put Donald Trump back in that White
House.
They are going to be on fire to flip Congress
as we were when we felt the threat of their
own party power.
Right.
And, you know, the Democrats hope is that,
oh, if Biden's relatively personally popular,
if we do a couple of these big packages, things
will just be fine.
And that's that was not an unreasonable hope
in nineteen ninety or maybe even in the early
2000s, but not now because we have a distinct
behavior in the electorate, as you just pointed
out, as show is Donald Trump's term in office.
There was everything on hyper drive, but also
different because it wasn't abstract stuff
that we care about.
It was pandemic is coming to kill you, your
family, take all your stuff, you know, kill
your personal wealth, everything.
Right.
And if you still end up with the same contest
I told you you would end up with six months
before the election, almost to the letter,
I said this is exactly how 20, 20 will play
out.
That means something is really wrong with
your political system, because when a giant
stimulus comes in like that, there should
be reaction.
Right.
Like the thing that we should have seen in
a healthy if if politics didn't need to change
from the 80s, in the 90s, then we wouldn't
have seen a repeat of twenty sixteen and not
in 1980.
Reagan Carter shellacking.
Speaker 1: Right now along those lines, I
mean, when you talk about policy and all these
different things, the Republican Party is
not really a party of policy anymore.
It's communism and socialism are going to
take over.
Mitch McConnell is great because he stops
Democrats from doing things critical race
theory, et cetera.
So how do you run against that?
How do you if you're what do Democrats need
to do?
Right.
Speaker 5: That's the frustrating part, is
it's really easy to run against that, but
not if you're tinkering in the lead and the
limbs of the tree.
OK, like their system is built like that,
like they've built.
And Michael Steele is me and him and I are
like tandem.
He was on TV last night on Brian Williams,
the show trying to explain to people, look,
this is we go in there and we we just decimate
your brand like we the reason they don't need
policy or achievements and I tweeted about
this last night, is that it's not to tell
the electorate that sees there.
It's not even about here's A or B, it's about
B sucks so much that it is going to come and
is going to drink the blood of your children.
Right.
I mean, that's what they're getting over there.
So what right back is is I mean as many things
as a strategic revolution.
That's a tactical deployment revolution.
But it's also I mean, most critically, it's
a messaging revolution because it takes the
convert the whole thing away from this.
Should we mobilize the base or persuade independents?
Because that's a that that's a it doesn't
matter what the answer is, A or B, because
that's not the world we live in right now.
And it readjusts the whole thing for the root
up to a branding war.
Right.
And when you're in that posture, you want
to be putting them on defense.
And the way to do that isn't to defend yourself
against TRT and defend the police.
And it doesn't matter where to disappear.
Everybody that ever held that position, they
would still bring in every candidate from
the moderate moderate all the way down as
a defund the police socialism.
That's what they'll do to Valdete means we
already know what they're going to do.
Right.
So, like, you can't escape that label.
What you can do is go on offense with them
and make them own.
And the nice thing is you don't have to distort
like no Democrat wants to defund the police.
But now the whole party has arrived at this
position on the Republican side, the things
that we're attacking them for, things are
doing the real things that everybody supports
that are the party's congressional leadership
are doing.
And you're going to have to get hyperbolic,
even though it sounds hyperbolic.
It's just the facts.
Right?
And so you make it so that the electorate
has to choose in South Florida, OK, socialism,
right?
Boy, don't give me a three hundred dollar
child care tax credit or military coup.
What, you pick South Florida, because I can
tell you this, down in South Florida, those
populations are afraid of socialism in South
America.
But you know what else they're afraid of?
Right wing military coups.
You look at South American history and what
has destabilized, destabilized South America
just as much is like the Republican Party
has put in right now in the lab.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think the complexity
in South Florida, I was just down there is
Cuban-Americans don't care about right wing
military involvement.
They like it and they want to go into Cuba.
Other being from Argentina myself and having
a sense of the different the different groups
there, that's complex.
Let me ask you this intuitively.
It seems to me that a lot of Trump's twenty
four potential is based on whether he can
successfully play kingmaker in twenty two,
whether Marjorie Taylor Greene gets reelected,
whether Lauran Bobert gets reelected, et cetera.
Is that an accurate assessment or does that
not really, no.
Speaker 5: I mean partially, David, because
Marjorie Taylor Green and Bobert are I mean,
that's the thing is it's so hard to have this
like encyclopedic knowledge of the apparatus
of how elections actually work.
And all that matters in a race is what percent
of Republican voters and they're left and
they're in these inbetweeners are going to
be voting in that electorate versus the other
side.
So like.
A district like bowerbirds or especially greens,
they're not ever getting tossed out of their
seat right there draw those districts are
not drawn in a competitive way,
Speaker 1: even from even from a Republican
challenge.
You think that they're good for as long as
they want those seats?
Speaker 5: Oh, yeah.
They're never going to beat back.
I mean, you have got to go, Charlie.
No, I mean, even after the Holocaust, I mean,
the horrible offensive stop with the Jewish
the vaccine badges.
Yeah, I'm telling you more murderer Taylor
Green.
It's like trying to go primary AOC on our
side.
And I know guys like as soon as I say, oh,
they're not the same and they're not and they're
nothing alike.
Yeah.
But the one way that they are like is that
they serve in districts that are not drawn
to be competitive between the parties.
Yeah.
And so like they have these distinctly ideological
electorates that they satisfy.
And so so the question is this the you know,
the answer to your question is this like,
OK, you're not going to those two and so you
don't want to turn them into symbolic, you
know, measurements.
But it is true that if we can, we beat back
the mid-term fundamentals here and we keep
Donald Trump from being even in contention
to become speaker of the House, because that's
the plan.
The speaker of the House doesn't have to come.
It's never been true that they've been so
rude to their own membership that they would
go recruit an outsider.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the rules are there.
And if McCarthy thinks for one second, one
second that Donald Trump isn't he doesn't
have his eye on that speakership, especially
since he's banished out in basically that
Superman world where they put the villains
out in space and they're rotating out in that
space.
That's where Trump is his only point to come
back into the public debate every day.
And and in a way that they have to cover him.
They don't have a choice.
Is that speakership?
Because otherwise he's going to stay over,
at least to some degree.
The media is aware of how they are culpable
in his rise and his tenure.
Right.
So they're not going to just open the door
to him.
But if he breaks it down.
Right.
So you really everything.
I mean, they have the physical power, the
like the legal power to not certify elections
if they take control in twenty twenty two.
Right.
I mean, I don't know anybody watching this
party could come to any other conclusion and
they're going to fight twenty four, do their
best to win it.
And then if they don't win it, win it anyway.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
As we've seen them claim from two a.m. on
November of twenty twenty, that also is, it's
crazy to call it a strategy, but it's a tactic
at least I guess I guess we could say that.
Speaker 5: No, it's not crazy to call it a
strategy, OK, because this is something that
got articulated as did election narrative
that trump the media.
All Trump's big lie was the whole Republican
Party's big lie.
And they began to cede its antecedence months
before November of twenty twenty.
And they put all of this legwork in place,
but if so, that they could get it tight margins
in Pennsylvania, Wisconsin, Michigan.
Right.
A preventing those ballots from arriving and
getting counted until election night ballots
came which were anticipated to disproportionately
break for Trump.
So they were creating strategically a situation
on election night where Trump would be ahead
in the vote count.
The other ballots have been blocked, at least
from that initial night of coverage.
Right.
And then they could contest court.
Now ended up a wrinkle in that plan because
the margins were large, just large enough
in Wisconsin and large enough in Wisconsin
and Michigan to to make that really hard.
And still, what did they do?
They went for it.
Right.
Never make any single mistake as a hot mess
as they are over there.
The thing that they are looping us on is strategic
planning and implementation of those plans.
They always, where I call us, Walking Dead
zombies.
We're kind of stumbling along into the next
human sets of human activity and then like,
oh, we should go deal with that right there.
Over there, like Velociraptors.
Yeah.
And they're executing it on.
And now we can't afford to be we can't afford
to be aimless and some really that strategic
overhaul.
I mean, we're better on issues or better on
policy and all the wonky.
But guys like the environment that we're in,
the one thing we're not better on is strategy
and we're making and we damn well better fix
it quick.
Speaker 1: Yeah, a point I made earlier on
on today's podcast.
Rachel Bit of Cougher, election forecaster,
analyst, host of the Election Whisperer podcast
and also the founder of Strike PAC.
Rachel, always a pleasure speaking with you.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
And I urge everybody to go to strike PAC's
website, see what these messaging that's brand
offensive branding, messaging looks like.
And if you can support us.